[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue d'un point de
vue c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
autour de nos deux débatteurs du jour
bonsoir mathieu soupière pour soi et
vous êtes consultant expert associé à la
fondation jean jaurès et vous allez
conseillé plusieurs ministres madame
bornes myriam el khomri dans un autre
temps c'était sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande et jérôme sainte-marie
est avec nous aussi bon soir jérôme ont
forcé deux politologues sondeurs
président fondateur de l'institut pôle
inbox et vous avez écrit c'est votre
dernier livre c'est pas le seul bloc
contre bloc ça a été publié aux éditions
du cerf
on commence si vous le voulez bien par
cette surprise l'arrivée du président de
la république dans nos petits écrans cet
égard soir vers 8h20 sur tf1 et lci
personne n'était au courant le chef de
l'état sort d'une réunion avec les
patrons des grands laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et il arrive avec
presque un cadeau de noël
regardez en quelques semaines c'est à
dire début mars nous aurons vacciner
l'ensemble des pensionnaires de maisons
de retraite ce qu'on appelle les ehpad
qui ont souhaité 80% souhaitait se
représente environ 500 mille de nos
concitoyens ils seront tous vaccinés
début mars on aura vacciner largement au
delà de ces établissements dans cette
période aussi les plus de 75 ans nous
allons continuer cette stratégie et
d'ici à la fin de l'été nous aurons
proposé en france à tous les français
adultes qui le souhaitent un vaccin
à ce que vous croyez ou non à ses
promesses présidentielles dites nous ce
que vous en pensez sur sur twitter sur
youtube et sur lefigaro.fr
on va bien sûr le demander à nos deux
débatteurs mais avant je vous propose
d'écouter ce point de vue de patrick
kanner c'est le patron du groupe
socialiste au sénat lui trouve que cette
intervention d'hier elle et pas
forcément très rassurante
c'est pas bon signe quand même pour la
gestion globale de cette communication
qui manifestement est très très
chaotique donc moi j'ai envie de croire
le président ben moi je suis un citoyen
comme les autres j'ai envie aussi d'être
vacciné le plus vite possible ce qui à
ce rythme là je serai à vacciner en 2000
22-23-24 potez aujourd'hui les chiffres
ne sont pas à la hauteur de l'espérance
qui vient d'être annoncé par le
président de la république
jérôme sainte-marie vous y croyez à ses
promesses présidentielles
ce que je retiens déjà c'est que c'est
une promesse c'est une promesse qui
intervient finalement assez tard ça fait
longtemps qu'on parle de vaccination
nous présente comme une aubaine quelque
chose qui aurait pu être fait ou qui a
été fait dans d'autres pays
depuis un certain temps après c'est une
promesse maintenant il faut qu'elle soit
tenue
et puis le faire ce qu'on ira une
communication de ce genre juste en
sortant d'une réunion
ça nous donne l'impression que le
président république était aussi surpris
que nous c'est à dire qu'il a du coup il
ya eu la découverte mais aussi que
c'était possible et donc il veut à tout
prix le faire savoir
ça pose un des soutes sortes de
problèmes ça a été soulignée par
l'ancien ministre me succéder à patrick
kanner notamment cette flex est pas
rassurant sur la gestion globale
le président de république à parler de
stratégie mais là on est plutôt dans le
coup tactique que la stratégie s'il ya
une stratégie elle serait énoncer
clairement à ces états pourrait indiquer
depuis longtemps c'est pas d'ailleurs si
ça serait pas d'ailleurs absurde que ce
soit le ministre de la santé qu'il
annonce plutôt donc en quelque sorte ça
serait plutôt rassurant si vous voulez
pour nous et pour les français en
général de se dire que les instituts des
administrations fonctionnent que chacun
est à sa place que ils ont quand même
une petite visibilité et que les prix
dans la république lui doit donner le
cadre général mais pourquoi est-ce que
c'est lui qui annonce souvent de petit
musée une nouvelle qui va laisser les
français à mon avis très
et plutôt envie de croire en plus les
chiffres annoncés sont pas énormes ce
qu'on y réfléchisse 1 500 ne sais pas
c'est pas extraordinaire
d'accord mais vivement ce qu'elle
souhaite d'ici la fin de l'été et vous
vous rendez compte d'ici la fin de l'été
c'est incroyable ça signifie déjà ce
qu'on entend ça signifie quand même que
cette tension va durer en fait on
apprend là on a la promesse de promesses
ses promesses les vaccins et la promesse
subsidiaire mais très importante pour
les français ça signifierait donc il n'y
a pas de troisième confinement si les
plus vulnérables sont assez rapidement
protéger ses enlève une énorme
justification 1,3 troisième confinement
ça c'est pas mal mais il ya aussi une
annonce qui est un peu moins comment
dirais-je enthousiasmante
c'est l'idée qu'on va rester dans cette
situation de gestion de semis
confinement et ces deux contraintes
assez forte sur les personnes et sur
l'économie
jusqu'à la fin des tpg vous passez la
parole matthew k bien sûr mais avant
voici ce que pensent les internautes du
figaro puisque c'est la question du jour
et on va dire qu'ils sont modérément
convaincu sur les cinquante huit mille
votants au presque 58 mille votants qui
se sont exprimés les deux tiers
considèrent que la promesse l'engagement
des manuels macron de vacciner tous les
français qui le souhaite d'ici la fin de
l'été n'est pas crédible est ce que vous
êtes moins sévère que nos internautes
mathieu soupière à tout le moins je suis
effectivement extrêmement surpris de la
façon dont les choses se sont
orchestrées d'accord au moins emmanuel
macron au pouvoir concerne cette
capacité qu'il a à ne pas être là où on
l'attend on l'attendait la semaine
dernière avec une prise de parole quasi
annoncée en milieu de semaine dernière
pour nous annoncer une mauvaise nouvelle
c'est à dire improbable confinement ou à
tout le moins un durcissement en fait de
la situation et ils parlent pas la
semaine dernière ils parlent une semaine
plus tard totalement par surprise
puisque avec lyon personne n'était au
courant et pas fera annoncer une
mauvaise nouvelle mais pour annoncer ce
qui du coup en fait apparaît comme une
excellente nouvelle terre que s'il dit
vrai à la fin de l'été donc tous les
français potentiellement tous les
français si nous voulons tous
conformément à la promesse macro nien
nous pourrions tous être vaccinés à la
fin de l'été c'est effectivement assez
audacieux alors je ensuite la prise de
risque
souvent partie du maquereau nisme dans
la sa passion de la disruption il y à il
ya deux façon quasi intrinsèque en fait
quasi implicite la notion de risque
il avait pris un premier risque au
moment du premier confinement quand ils
avaient annoncé contre la plupart des
conseils que qu'on lui donne et autour
de lui la date du 11 mai tout le monde
trouvait ça et en particulier à matignon
où edouard philippe incarné à la raison
et la prudence
emmanuel lacroix avait donné le
sentiment de forcer un petit peu les
choses
en annonçant cette date du 11 mai qui
avait fait du bien au moral des français
alors je ne sais pas si là il tente de
rééditer la même chose mais on voit bien
que il a refusé les conseils très
prudent conclut produit à la semaine
dernière et qui disaient tous un recond
finement est inéluctable pour ne pas du
tout se positionner sur la question du
dur confinement mais pour se projeter
dès à présent dans une perspective
heureuse à moins de six mois
cette promesse ne me rappelle une autre
promesse présidentielle qui avait été
politiquement très risquée
c'était celle de françois hollande sur
l'inversion la courbe du chômage il y a
dans le mal chronique dans le maquereau
nisme une promesse de professionnalisme
de d'autorité et d'efficacité dans la
gestion des affaires publiques à travers
cette stratégie vaccinale qui devrait
déboucher donc de façon totalement
favorable est totalement positive selon
président de la république à la fin de
l'été il ya une forme de promesses si la
promesse n'est pas tenue
on voit mal comment en septembre à
l'automne à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 ça sonnera en
fait là pour le coup le début de
l'entrée en campagne présidentielle si
la promesse n'est pas tenue
on peut imaginer qu emmanuel macron se
situe exactement dans la mission de
françois hollande hier cinq ans et la
d'impuissance de d'incapacité à pouvoir
se représenter autant dire que le risque
est élevé on espère que ça se passera
mieux pour lever que lors de la promesse
de françois hollande est pour tous les
français qui veulent se faire vacciner
absolue d'ailleurs ils sont
pas tous volontaires et nos internautes
le rappelle volontiers sng x sur youtube
qui nous dit oui on arrivera à vacciner
tous les français parce que personne ne
veut se faire vacciner et anne sur
youtube ça dépendra du nombre de
français convaincus de l'utilité de ce
vaccin alors il ya quand même une
réponse à nos deux internautes c'est le
chiffre qu'a donnée le président de la
république hier soir
80% des personnes âgées est pensionnaire
des pad ont souhaité se faire vacciner
donc il semblerait que l'adhésion soit
quand même assez massive en tout cas à
cette génération
et puis qu'est-ce que nous avons
d'autres comme réaction à mon sens le
manque de vaccins remettent en question
beaucoup de choses nous dit julien
belles vues sur youtube à nouveau alors
là encore la pression d'un public qui
hier a annoncé que le vaccin allait être
conditionnée par quatre laboratoires
français qui à défaut d'en avoir trouvé
un pourront au moins aider à la
manoeuvre les laboratoires qui ont déjà
obtenu la certification c'est à dire
pfizer bio ntech moderna est désormais
astrazeneca ou une fois qu'il a
également un autre élément d'incertitude
je prolonge le raisonnement de nattier
soupière là dessus puisque effectivement
donc ça serait à la fin de l'été tout ça
serait déterminée en quelque sorte
mais encore faut-il qu à la fin de l'été
les premiers vaccins soient encore
pertinent six mois plus tard c'est toute
la question qu'on se pose par rapport
aux variants est ce que les variants
fond vous ne vont pas rendre en quelque
sorte en partie obsolètes les vaccins
que tout médecin donc voilà je vous
parle dans le joli un peu les choses
effectivement ces variants s'ils sont si
la mutation est assez importante
est ce que ces vaccins seront pertinents
alors par ailleurs il ya une habilité
dans le discours de
de l'exécutif ces derniers mois cas
plutôt pas mal fonctionné d'ailleurs et
là c'est le sondeur qui parlent ce qu'on
ait fait des sondages là dessus c'est de
transformer un problème de logistique en
problème d'opinion c'est à dire qu'on
s'est posé souvent la question ici même
d'ailleurs sur l'acceptabilité sociale
du vaccin ce qui a permis de
culpabiliser pas mal les français qui
seraient réticents à la science etc
enfin sortant on trouve ça très normal
donc le bac ça c'est pas mon problème
donc il veut un débat qui s'est
installée assure un vaccin qui était pas
disponible
donc c'est dire que la saaq est peu
caché l'impuissance
il revient pas du gouvernement de l'état
tout simplement et du tissu économique
français
une issue scientifiques français à
fournir ces vaccins qui existe dans les
mêmes conditions dans d'autres pays et
l'a finalement ne rentrer dans un truc
où s'affrontent ou et tout ça finit par
dire les français sont réticents sont
ceux ci sont crédules ou au contraire
seront incrédule mais ce n'est même pas
le problème le problème c'est bien la
logistique et là on va le retrouver quoi
il ya un autre sujet matthieu se classe
sur lequel le chef de l'état a voulu
convaincre les français hier c'était que
l'europe avait fait les bons choix et il
a dit d'ailleurs avec cette drôle de
formule
nous nous sommes nous nous faisant
vacciner en européen
voilà est-ce que vous pensez que là
aussi il peut convaincre
on sait que dans plusieurs pays d'europe
y compris en allemagne d'ailleurs les
oppositions 10 lors pas été trop lente
regardez les britanniques se sont bien
mieux sorti que nous les israéliens les
américains parce que parce qu'ils n'ont
pas fait bloc est ce que vous pensez que
là il ya un point de faiblesse dans la
dans l'argumentaire présidentielle je
sais pas s'il ya un point de faiblesse
dans l'argumentaire présidentielle en
tout état de cause il ya un risque c'est
que l'europe devienne un nouveau bouc
émissaire dans cette affaire
effectivement par contraste on pointe le
fait que la dictature chinoise par
exemple serait dans la gestion de cette
crise plus efficace que ne le serait les
démocraties voir l'autoritarisme russe
de monsieur coûte exactement exactement
donc il ya un enjeu européen alors
ensuite en général on voit le verre à
moitié vide ou à moitié plein en
fonction des convictions qui sont les
siennes c'est peu dire effectivement que
l'europe c'est une bureaucratie qui en
l'espèce ne parvient pas à obtenir la
quantité de vaccins qu'elle s'était
engagée à avoir bon je sais pas si c'est
l'europe qui est responsable de ça on
voit bien que sous la pression des
opinions est sous la pression des
gouvernants les labos ont probablement
été un tout petit peu ambitieux ou un
tout petit peu imprudent ils ont voulu
probablement assurer une production
qu'ils ne sont aujourd'hui pas en
capacité de fournir d'aucun je suis pas
sûr que ce soit l'europe qui seront en
réalité fautive là dedans mais on peut
voir le verre à moitié plein aussi en se
disant dans la gestion de cette pandémie
de secret de cette crise sanitaire
mondiale quand même il y a eu une forme
de coopération internationale la
première coopération elle s'est
clairement fait au niveau européen
l'europe s'est soudée autour de cette
affaire alors que encore une fois la
santé ne fait pas partie de ses
compétences
et aujourd'hui encore dans la stratégie
vaccinale on voit qu'il ya malgré tout
une volonté d'opérer de façon coordonnée
or on se critique est en 1re phase 2 de
gestion de la crise de confinement sur
le fait qu'il pouvait y avoir des
stratégies nationales différentes et
surtout incohérente
le fait que l'europe essaye de mettre de
la cohérence dans tout ça et qu'il n'y
ait pas une guerre une concurrence
acharnée entre les pays européens dans
la course au vaccin est plutôt une bonne
chose en réalité je suis ravi ce que
j'en pense à trouver un terrain de 17
heures
je ne comprends pas déjà l'europe
valorise la concurrence donc on va pas
se désole du fait qu'il ya une
concurrence entre les états et entre
puisqu'au fond justement cela met de
l'eau dans son vin depuis quelques
années quand même sur ce sujet là donc
l'accord donne effectivement on est
libre et la recherche dans 27 états etc
c'est donc déjà c'est un peu
contradictoire avec cela mais surtout
est ce qu'on pense sérieusement que si
on était uniquement dans le cadre
national
les choses auraient été aurait été pire
c'est je ne vois pas pourquoi
d'autant plus on a l'exemple de petits
pays je pense à israël par exemple 7
millions de personnes qui a réussi quand
même une stratégie vaccinale alors après
il ya un débat par rapport aux
palestiniens mais la population disons
qu'il n'est pas israélienne de
nationalité mais et au cou négocié par
israël mais il ya une efficacité
indiscutable assez impressionnante pour
un tout petit état il ya aussi être un
peu le britannique
on rappelle que le royaume uni a décidé
d'acheter des vaccins de son côté alors
même qu'ils étaient encore dans l'union
européenne donc c'était avant le break
si l'on dit loeb ça va pas assez vite
nous on va s'organiser à je crois
qu'effectivement les grès de l'union
enfin le royaume uni du bre de site
n'est pas exactement la catastrophe
sanitaire
certains aimeraient voir ou en tout cas
que certains aimeraient dénoncer mais
parce que là effectivement on voit pas
si vous voulez effectivement qu'elle est
et jusqu'à présent le bénéfice de
l'europe depuis le début de la crise on
n'a de toutes façons de nouveau
l'existence du cadre national ne serait
ce que par la fermeture des frontières
nationales et que donc de ce point de
vue là je crois quand même qui va être
venir très difficile mais je vous
encourage à le faire parce que la place
n'est pas dépaysé elle est donc
nécessaire mais à défendre le bilan de
l'union européenne dans cette matière
alors il ya quand même une communauté de
vie et d'intérêts en europe qui fait qu'
il y a aujourd'hui des mêmes des
mouvements de populations encore en
europe dire que quand on on se dit qu'on
fonctionne au ralenti en réalité
l'europe reste un espace de vie commune
et donc le fait que l'europe se dote de
règles communes dans la gestion de la
crise sanitaire ne me paraît pas de
mauvaises méthodes si l'on parallélisme
des du raisonnement pour ezio mais même
les états pourquoi confier sa des états
nationaux après tout il ya des
présidents de région qui réclame qui
réclamait en tout cas il ya quinze jours
trois semaines la possibilité de
commander pour eux mêmes des vaccins
laissons les régions faire si enfin je
danse cac small is beautiful
et soyons au plus près du terrain et la
concurrence libre et non faussée entre
conseils régionaux pourrait là encore
garantir de l'efficacité je suis patient
of ages
encore une fois je pense qu'on a tout à
gagner quand même à ce que l'europe qui
parfois manqué un peu de chair est un
peu de bien commun puisse gagner en
efficacité autour de cette notion de la
santé ça encore une fois il y a de toute
façon des mouvements au sein de l'union
européenne qui justifie que les
stratégies puissent être coordonnés ça
ne sert à rien en fait d'avoir des
français vaccinés si les allemands à
côté ne sont pas car ils gardent il y
aura toujours une porosité entre la
france elle a démarré avec les plus du
maghreb vous savez les échanges humains
sont très importants que peu du maghreb
on trouve là des solutions d'ailleurs
leur réelle de sanitaires sont souvent
beaucoup plus strictes que les nôtres en
réalité les quarantaines tout cela est
donc les échanges humains sont aussi là
non c'est plutôt au niveau s'ils
voulaient de la production justement de
vaccins la production de masques etc
on a bien vu que les abandons de
souveraineté nous ont rendus extrêmement
vulnérables en tout cas c'est la mairie
ce que je vais faire et c'est tout le
charme de ce débat c'est qu'elle ne sera
pas forcément partagé le petit bémol
c'est que au moment où emmanuel macron
s'exprimer hier soir juste sur la forme
il a vocation à rassurer or le fait de
commandes organisé comme ça à l'arraché
une interview qui était prévu par
personne dans les conditions qui sont
faites jamais mal images marièrent et
blafarde
il est d'autres de porc il est acculé
dans un coin enfin le la mise en scène
est très étonnante
il est lui-même un peu pâlichon mais on
l'est tous en janvier février la mise en
scène la communication politique n'est
pas une science exacte mais on peut
quand même s'étonner de la façon dont
les choses son père mais sur le fond il
dit bien en france à la fin de l'été
tous ceux qui auront voulu se faire
vacciner auront pu le faire dans le même
temps on a une interview de la
présidente de la commission européenne
dans le monde qui dit qu' elle annonce
le chiffre de 70 % d'européens adultes
voilà donc le les chiffres par ailleurs
sont pas d'une absolue concordance me
semble-t-il
oui le match n'est pas joué encore et on
verra dans les mois à venir si les
promesses sont tenues
il ne s'agit pas de promesses ne corrige
madame de staël quel joli
le nîmes sur lefigaro.fr il ne s'agit
pas de promesses mais d'un engagement à
faire en sorte qu'on arrive à l'objectif
à même de l'obligation de faim et de
moyens et puis chantal tout cas sur
youtube qui nous dit de toute façon le
confinement doit être drastiques
tant que les vaccins ne seront pas
suffisants pour deux injections sur 60%
de la population mais voilà au moins une
recommandation qui est claire je vous
propose de nous pencher quelques
instants sur un sondage intéressant
l'élection présidentielle c'est l'année
prochaine et jusqu'à présent on ne
donnait pas vraiment cher d'une
candidature de gauche parce que emmanuel
macron et marine le pen semble est
occupé tout l'espace d'ailleurs le
raisonnement pourrait être valable aussi
pour un candidat de la droite dite
classique et puis voilà ce sondage
intéressant c'est un sondage ipsos sopra
steria pour nos confrères de l'ops et de
france info
qu'est-ce qui nous apprend ce sondage
nous apprend que si la gauche écologique
on va dire c'est à dire le parti
socialiste europe écologie les verts
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
eh bien ils vont se faire distancer dans
ces cas d'arnaud montebourg frais 4%
yannick jadot 7% anne hidalgo 8%
c'est-à-dire moins que jean luc
mélenchon et surtout moins que xavier
bertrand est beaucoup moins qu emmanuel
macron et marine le pen bref ils se
retrouvent pas au second tour
en revanche si ça arrive à s'entendre
alors là il ya peut-être un trou de
souris
une occasion à saisir et c'est le
deuxième enseignement de ce sondage
l'institut a testé une candidature dany
d'algos avec la présence au premier tour
de jean luc mélenchon est là anne
hidalgo monte à 16 % c'est-à-dire elle
fait jeu égal avec et xavier bertrand et
si c'est yannick jadot qui est candidat
alors on arrive à 17 % c'est-à-dire que
ça re devient jouable
bref jérôme sainte marie si cette gauche
réformiste qu'intelligente
elle va s'entendre il faut remarquer
dans ce sondage que le combat de la
gauche là c'est pour la troisième place
16 17% savoir s'ils seront ou pas devant
le candidat fort que l'examen bertrand
qui a testé la le candidat de la droite
classique
si on peut dire mais de toute façon ils
sont troisièmes mais ils sont parés au
second tour yak de plus en troisième et
ils sont donc très loin de l'ordre de 8
points à peu près par rapport à bassoues
en place un qui généralement occupés en
sondages par emmanuel macron pas
toujours mais bien plusieurs fois
ensuite vous avez fait preuve la
première chose c'est un sondage qui
contredit en partie ou en tout cas qui
est assez différent d'autres sondages
qu'on a pu voir en octobre le sondage
ifop montrait qu'un candidat unique de
la gauche
c'était 13% pour jade autres restent
pour cent pour les algues aux 15% pour
monsieur sous des mois mélenchon et ça
prouve est d'ailleurs qu'on partait à
peu près dispersé de plus de 20% presque
25%
quand on ne mettait un candidat unique
continue division réel de la gauche et
des écologistes on arrivait à 13 15 % là
c'est beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup plus
avec en plus cette
cette pression qui va être énorme
d'ailleurs c'est un sondage qui va
mettre d une tension terrible à gauche
puisque 17% pour monsieur jadot 16% pour
madame hidalgo
il voit aussitôt dire regardez dans ce
cas là on peut être il faut demander à
jean luc mélenchon qui est testé la
gauche est très très haut dans ce
sondage la somme est étonné un peu et il
testé à 9 10 % donc on va dire
additionnez monsieur mélenchon retirer
vous laisser aller jadot ou
laisser-aller hidalgo la mécaniquement
si on regarde son réseau nic mans en
additionnant des scores de manière
totalement arbitraire à mon avis est
très artificielle surtout si on
additionne à ce moment là mais le score
de mélenchon et le score de jado oublia
d'hidalgo on arrive à 25 %
et là c'est plus le combat pour la
troisième place c'est le combat pour la
deuxième place et donc pour le second
tour et mais c'est très artificielle
c'est très artificielle parce que si je
parlais de ce sondage ifop et non pas du
harris interactive qui a manqué plus
son c'est parce que quand on regarde et
justement les candidatures uniques on
s'apercevait que ça ne s'additionnaient
pas du tout et je pense que ça ne
s'additionnera pas que par ailleurs la
jean luc mélenchon a peu de raisons en
réalité de ne pas se présenter
il a les moyens de le faire il a
l'équipe pour le faire l'argent pour le
faire il ya une vraie logique politique
disons que ça complique son jeu mais je
ne crois pas que ce soit exactement si
vous voulez la révolution politique que
nous indique le nouvel obs qui
visiblement aimerait bien faire exister
largement cette hypothèse écologistes
mais que je trouve encore une fois très
fragile
mathieu ce cas vous connaissez bien la
gauche est ce que vous pensez que ils
peuvent s'entendre
anne hidalgo si c'est elle qui arrivent
comme favorite pour le parti socialiste
et yannick jadot pour une candidature
unique
d'abord en terme de d'ambition de
personnes et ensuite en terme de
programme en termes de lignes politiques
on pourrait imaginer que ce soit le cas
ça fait longtemps que la gauche a
l'habitude de s'allier la gauche
plurielle des années jospin
ça a plutôt bien fonctionné cette gauche
plurielle elle s'est depuis lors décliné
à des niveaux locaux pour des exécutifs
municipaux ou des exécutifs régionaux
plutôt avec succès donc on parle de
partis qui en réalité ont l'habitude de
travailler ensemble depuis longtemps et
dont les convergences sont bien plus
importantes que les divergences voilà
alors ensuite on a un jean luc mélenchon
qui s'est éloigné malgré tout de cela
alors tactiquement et sur le fond mais
c'est vrai que jean luc mélenchon a pris
la tangente par rapport à ce qu est l
parti communiste l'allié traditionnel
d'avant ça c'est sûr ensuite je rejoins
jérôme seule chose qui le disaient
divisé on est quasiment sûr de perdre
unis on n'est pas du tout sûr de gagner
il ya eu une tentative d'unification
lors de la dernière présidentielle entre
benoît hamon et yannick jadot déjà
benoît hamon était sortie de sa primaire
de la gauche
auréolé d'une d'intentions de vote kiki
et s'était envolé jusqu'à 18%
jadot était beaucoup plus bas mais jadot
était venu dans la roue de benoît hamon
soi-disant lui apporter le renfort
nécessaire
hamon s'est effondré derrière il a fini
donc à six ou sept donc encore une fois
additionné des candidats ne n'additionne
pas des voix parce que une campagne
parlons de cette banalité mais c'est une
dynamique
et je crois pas que ce soit le nombre de
candidatures en fait
kiki qui pose question ce qui compte
c'est d'avoir parmi les candidatures les
diverses candidatures les multiples
candidatures d'avoir une candidature qui
puisse être une locomotive à un instant
t
quand françois hollande a été élu
président de la république
il avait au 1er tour à côté de lui
d'autres candidatures à gauche il a
réussi juste à finir premier et à finir
premiers dans des conditions qui
permettait aux autres candidats de la
gauche de venir lui donner l'impulsion
d'entre deux tours qui lui permettait
ensuite de battre nicolas sarkozy à
françois mitterrand lui-même 12 en 2010
au premier tour il y avait qui à gauche
il y avait mes longtemps déjà
il y avait chez les écolos eva joly si
je ne m'abuse
non je me trompe je ne sais plus crois
que c'était la jolie on n'a pas répété
donc voilà on n'a pas réjoui des il y
avait il y avait commandé par tu dois y
avait comme d'habitude une multitude de
petites candidatures à à l'extrême
gauche photo la différence que j'ai
effectivement en 2012 la gauche sans les
écologistes eva joly s'étaient 41% qui
bien sûr avec eva joly
suivez à 43 n'y avait pas la concurrence
la république embarqué il est là tant ce
qu'il faut c'est en fait le la faiblesse
d'un candidat de gauche qui peut
incarner quand même là la figure de la
locomotive victorieuse au deuxième tour
voilà et à ce stade encore une fois sa
pêche
je vous donne les avis de nos
internautes
kriss kross sur lefigaro.fr est
convaincu que yannick jadot ira tout
seul
nicole 06 qui se dit qu'ils font
peut-être alliance avant les élections
et comme d'habitude il se fâcheront et
se sépareront après
rassure car 38 nous demande sur le
figaro.fr ce qu'il ya de commun entre
mélenchon est les socialistes macro
compatibles c'est vrai que sans doute
pas grand chose est de moins en moins de
choses c'est pour ça que mon travail est
plutôt sur l'hypothèse
d'un rassemblement entre la gauche
sociale-démocrate et les écologistes et
puis et d'ail sur youtube qui nous dit
que l'écologie ne devrait pas être un
sujet politique tout le monde devrait
faire de l'écologie on parlait de
yannick jadot
on sent qu'il a un peu de mal à franchir
le rubicon il veut y aller mais il va
pas complètement
est ce que c'est la bonne stratégie
avant de nous donner votre avis vous
propose de l'écouter il était sur tf1
samedi dernier les françaises et les
français sont aujourd'hui plongés dans
l'angoissé
c'est pas le moment des candidatures
mais je veux participer à ce grand débat
à mettre sur la table des propositions
pour qu'on sorte de cette pandémie plus
fort pour qu'on sorte de cette pandémie
dans une société plus juste fier de se
retrousser les manches de se serrer les
coudes sur ce but belle et le grand
projet qu'est l'écologie politique
on sent qu'il rame un peu la donne il a
il a d'autres choix que celui là alors
je voudrais pas dire on aller j'y vais
ça vous donner mon pronostic a pas sur
les scores les cinq d'or ne font pas ça
un an et demi mais sur les candidatures
moi je crois sincèrement que il ya comme
il ya pas en plus de raisons que
mélenchon ne soit pas de candidat et que
s'il n'est pas candidat
enfin s'il accepte de soutenir mais ton
monsieur jadot est de mêler ses voix
avec lui non seulement il ne sera pas
suivi par tous ses électeurs mais en
plus ils risquent leur âme d il demeura
draka de négocier des conditions tout
cela il fera fuir des électeurs
potentiels de monsieur jadot qui iront
plutôt du côté de monsieur maquereau ou
qui répond à s'abstenir ou qui ronge à
un autre candidat qui pourrait
apparaître pour les recueillir
donc je ne crois pas si vous voulez du
tout à cette addition tant et si bien
que mon analyse est toujours la même
c'est à dire que je crois que les partis
ne sont pas ou les coalitions ne sont
pas faibles parce qu'ils sont divisés
mais ils sont divisés parce qu'ils sont
faibles comme je pense qu'effectivement
pour l'instant on ne voit pas apparaître
de sondages promettant la victoire pour
une gauche et les écologistes réunifiée
à ce moment là ils vont tous se dire à
commencer par les écologistes qui ont
intérêt à se présenter séparément
d'une part parce que ça peut bouger très
vite on a vu effectivement que son nez
pour monsieur hamon était passé de 18% à
6 % rentrée ya quelques semaines et
inversement mais mélenchon était monté
de 8 à presque 20 donc ça peut bouger
très vite et puis après derrière vous
savez on sait pas du tout quelle sera le
contexte politique dans un an et demi
est ce que ça vaut pas la peine d'être
candidat pour ensuite être
soit le premier représentant de
l'opposition soit alors mettons monsieur
mais macron soient élus de faire une
d'apporter ses voix au second tour et de
re de commencer une carrière
ministérielle
donc tout ça me paraît si vous voulez à
peu frein la probabilité politique qui
ressort en partie de ces sondages moi me
me semble indiquer une très forte
division et donc une élection qui se
passe un petit peu à côté de la gauche
on va dire les internautes partagent un
vos interrogations ou vos doutes nous
vous posons la question sur twitter
croyez vous à une alliance de la gauche
et des écologistes pour les prochaines
échéances électorales
et c'est non à 66% ou quasiment
mathieu souquet regard d'un qui
dégustent un dans le sondage de nos
confrères c'est arnaud montebourg donc
dans le cas c'était notre première la
première diapositives
dans le cas partout ces termes est un
peu un peu millénium par millenium un
peu comment est ce qu'on dit quand on
est vieux
/
les premiers chiffres quand vous avez
donné avec les premiers tours où pouvait
se présenter arnaud montebourg anne
hidalgo yannick jadot
montebourg est à 4% ça vous surprend ce
score qui est quand même très bas que
soupière hidalgo elle-même dans des
sondages il ya quelques semaines
quelques mois était elle-même très basse
alors que tout le monde l'a considérée
comme une candidate légitime donc je ne
sais pas dans quelle mesure on peut
interpréter ce truc là et dire que hamon
montebourg prend spécifiquement cheikh
dans ce dans ce sondage prouvent qu'ils
prennent tous assez cher à partir du
moment où à la question posée de qui
ferait un bon président de la république
tous les candidats de gauche se trouve
placé derrière françois hollande dont on
n'avait pas imaginé que dans l'opinion
collective il pouvait encore apparaître
comme la figure d'un taux président de
la république mais mme hidalgo et
derrière ils sont tous derrière alors
forcé forcément la séquence est très
compliqué pour la gauche
d'abord au niveau des forces sociales il
faut bien dire quand même que le pays
n'a jamais été aussi peu à gauche
qu'aujourd'hui les gens continuent à
croire au clivage gauche droite est
d'ailleurs pardon mais ce clivage go
alors je vais préciser ma pensée
la moitié d'abord d'abord le clivage
gauche droite il n'existe plus quand on
regarde les projections pour une
présidentielle où le duo deux finalistes
s'est encore effectivement cette année
enfin pardon pour 2022 potentiellement
le pen macron c'est vrai mais au niveau
local au niveau local on l'a vu avec les
municipales et on verra avec les
régionales l'année prudent que dans
quelques mois pardon c'est ce sont
encore les partis traditionnels de
gauche et de droite qui domine l'extrême
droite ne perde pas elle a pris
perpignan mais c'est vraiment pas grand
chose et les verts qu'on peut qualifier
quand même qu'on peut qu'on peut classer
à gauche ont pris effectivement
certaines grandes métropoles mais on
voit bien que au niveau local les forces
de la reine et les forces du
rassemblement national n'existe pas
alors qu'elles demeurent les deux
principales forces au niveau national
dans la projection d'une présidentielle
ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose au niveau des forces politiques
on comprend qu'elle soit encore très
affaibli compte tenu de la défaite
cinglante que la gauche a subi en 2017
souvenons nous que en 86
la gauche avait sacrément davis et aux
législatives quand 93 quand la gauche
est au pouvoir elle en sort en général
totalement essorer et il lui faut un
certain temps pour se remettre des caire
alors en 93 elle avait totalement bu la
tasse et elle avait quand même réussi à
se remettre ans
elle partiellement avec la
présidentielle de 95 et ensuite aux
législatives de 97 mais que cinq ans
après quatre ans après pardon la
déculottée qui a subi françois hollande
impuissante et incapable de se
représenter et avec le score que benoît
hamon a réussi à capter sur sa
candidature
on se dit que la reconstruction de la
gauche allait forcément nécessiter du
temps un mot de conclusion
oui je m'étonne un peu que mathieu sous
caire qui est infiniment plus jeune que
moi soit à ce poids ancien monde parce
que je me semble-t-il justement que et
on n'est pas là on a un paysage qui n'a
plus rien à voir avec l'époque où il y
avait une alternance gauche droite que
la gauche n'est pas perçue comme la
principale opposante à emmanuel macron
avec d'excellentes raisons puisque
d'ailleurs une partie de la gauche est
derrière et au gouvernement était
derrière électoralement ou concrètement
derrière emmanuel macron donc je ne
pense pas qu'elle soit de toute façon en
situation de profiter de l'usure du
pouvoir
emmanuel macron et même si effectivement
la au niveau national la transmutation
n'est pas complète
il demeure que les deux forces
principales qui apparaissent dans ce
sondage qui sont apparus aux européennes
sont apparus en 2017 sont deux forces
qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans le
clivage gauche droite à savoir bien sûr
le maquereau nisme et le lepénisme
et c'est aussi le point de vue de jean
michel marc sait pas si les parents de
l'autre sur le figaro.fr qui viennent
ici en tout cas il est depuis ce qu'il
nous dit il est clair que le seul qui
rassemble au second tour c'est emmanuel
macron merci beaucoup à lire les deux
merci merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
et à demain pour d'autres prochain point
de vue
il
[Musique]